business is creating something that you
believe in most of the best
entrepreneurial ideas come out of
frustration I think if you can run if
you can run one business well you can
run any business he's the founder of the
Virgin Group which controls over 400
companies the Virgin brand grew rapidly
in the 1980s as he said of the Virgin
Atlantic airline company in 2016 Forbes
listed his net worth as 5.2 billion
dollars he's Richard Branson and here's
my take on his top ten rules for success
volume two rule number two is my
personal favorite and I'm curious if
you're growing which one you guys like
the best also guys as you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired by your
sharing and also when you write it down
you're much more likely to lock it in
for yourself to enjoy
I think the important thing to think
about business is if the business isn't
really business and business is creating
something that you believe in I mean the
most successful entrepreneurs the people
like Larry Page and Sergey who had an
idea in their garage and felt they could
create something called Google in all of
these examples they are filling a niche
in in in different areas and just making
making living most people a lot more
pleasant than it was before I think it's
a mistake when people think of business
like they're bringing up a till in a in
a shop for most entrepreneurs business
is very creative and a great adventure I
think if you if you believe in what
you're doing
you know many people will tell you you
know what why you're mistaken right a
little work you know but if you really
believe passionate what you're doing
just just then I keep going you know
keep pushing on keep pushing on and
until you either succeed or at least you
realize that you know it's just it's
just not going to happen
and and and then if it if you don't
succeed pick yourself up and and you
know try again and and ultimately you
know if you you know if you're that
determined you will succeed in life and
then and if you don't you'll have a have
a lot of fun trying
I started literally in a really small
way and like handing out leaflets
outside and outside concert halls and
selling you know selling music getting
getting the money in from the leaflets
and then and then sending the music out
and you know just one thing led onto
another so you don't have to dream big
straight away just try to get the nuts
and bolts of your business going you
know that
whatever job you're doing in life you
know if you're if you're a switchboard
operator if you're cleaning the floors
of a building you know if you're you
know placing eggs or an incubator
whatever it is if you you know if you're
positive about the job you're doing
you're going to get you're going to be a
much happier person and the people
around you're going to be a lot happier
and it's likely that you know that you
won't forever be a cleaning lady or you
period because you know because you're
smiling because you're happy people will
you know promote you and you'll you'll
go on and do great things in life I
think a positive attitude is essential
in life whatever your position looks
like you always go out of your comfort
zone right coming on to an island that
was completely deserted no fresh water
you didn't have the money to buy it and
and now you're sleeping on a tent on the
beach trying to figure out how to get
fresh water here you do that often you
did it with the airline I mean I was
just somebody that experienced a bad
experience of traveling on Airlines I
was actually trying to get to the BVI
the bridge goes down it's one day from
Puerto Rico and the same lovely lady was
waiting for me and I've been away for
three weeks and American Airlines bumped
the flight and and so I went to the back
of the airport I had a plane I had a
blackboard I wrote Virgin Airlines
one-way $29 to the VV I went to run all
the people have been bumped and I filled
my first plane and and that got me
thinking you know that Airlines to bump
people they don't care about your me
particularly in the air and so we so
then rang up Boeing and said you have
any second and seven for seven okay I
mean it was literally that you just at
any Airport and so I'm starting an
airline right now because I'm frustrated
exactly and I think most most of the
best entrepreneurial ideas come out of
frustration I think you know if you if
you're frustrated about something and
the best way of sorting it out is get
out and do it and you've got yourself a
business life is short life should be
fun and it should be fun not you know it
should be if the the chairman of the
company is having fun you
you go to a party and you know if I let
my hair down and I'm the first to be
throwed in the swimming pool and and I'm
not just physically there standing in
the corner of the room sipping sherry or
something then everybody will have a
laugh and everybody has a fun you know
if you're Gemma come buddy be the first
to dance on the table you know just get
everybody else up dancing on the table
and make sure the parties you know the
parties are last so you know so play
hard and play hard work hard and then
and you know follow certain principles
and life's gonna be you know you know
love people make make sure you make a
positive difference in this world but
while you're on it over the next five
years we plan to take on the banking
community we plan to take on the
cosmetics industry we plan to take on
the clothing industry and
telecommunications and one or two other
industries and see whether we can give
them a run for their money and do it
slightly differently than it's been why
do you think you can do it mainly
because I think we've got a fantastic
team of people we attract good people
and their skills are translatable to
whatever the industry is it's creating
harmony it's risk orientation it's what
I think if you can run if you can run
one business well you can run any
business and if you know that what
matters in business is a good team of
people well motivated team of people
incentivize well giving a lot of freedom
to go out and prove themselves and you
can pretty well achieve anything the key
the key to I think being a good business
leader is is your is how good you are
with people I think if you can care it
genuinely care about people not just
your fellow directors but you know the
cleaning lady the switchboard operator
you know everybody throughout the
company you know if you're a good you
know if you've praised and don't
criticize you know people people will
flourish and so I think you know it's
really your people skills that will set
you set you apart and and
and I don't think that can be over
overemphasized and just you just got to
and you know if I get if I'm on a virgin
plane I will make sure that I always
have a notebook in my back pocket and
you know make sure I get out and talk to
all the staff you know if they've got
issues you know make sure I don't just
you know hear the issue and not write it
down make sure those those issues get
written down you know talk to the
passengers if they've got issues make
sure those issues get written down I
honestly just don't think about mistakes
but let me see if I can time and I just
liked it if I make a mistake I put it
behind me and I just move move move move
forward but approach a good spot you
know and and you know yet you know I
mean there have been you know music
musical bands that I've missed trying to
sign like dad straight you know they've
been companies that have fallen flat on
their face like virgin Cola you know but
I you know but you know that's just part
of that's just part of them you know
being an entrepreneur you but you're
going to have these things happening all
the time so I don't really see them as
mistakes you're just and you know
they're just you know if you're an
entrepreneur because some things are not
going to go right something is going to
go right
they'll kill me
in one area you
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a magnet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay thank you very much if I were to
say to another the life of working with
always having crews and want to say
thank you very much my ex and we have a
few back again - I don't think I'm going
to be and now you come back on on the
play game system but it's been great fun
thanks very much
stick with it thank raising a lot longer
life and make that distinction he's in a
warm region welcome to our new classroom
Sir Richard Branson
[Music]
I won't be hiring since I own the
company which it will not be hired in
fact right now I'm firing him regular a
postman is the Starlight foundation
where we had a wonderful flight and you
know while I'm here and try to
congratulate her in all the wonderful
Steven AirAsia and AirAsia X for the
incredible job they've done are they've
transformed traveling out of the nation
and around Asia and they deserve all the
credit for it and it was I always wanted
to be an effort that coming place looks
like it looked like I was going to
absolutely normality but anyway thank
you very much for coming
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video and in general what do you think
of our volume 2 series please leave a
comment down below I'd also love to know
what did you learn from Richard today
what was your favorite clip and why what
lesson are you going to immediately
apply to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
super curious to find out finally I want
to give a quick shout at the Shema thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I think you know it's sort of foolish to
spend your life not for not not becoming
expert at your passions if you're
passionate about something you're going
to give it you're going to give it your
all and and you're going to enjoy
learning about it whereas if you have no
interest in it you're not going to
you're not going to lap it up I was
flying from the British Virgin Islands
that's very from Puerto Rico to the
British Virgin Islands and and I was 28
years old and I been away from home for
three weeks and I this gorgeous lady
waiting for me and and American Airlines
announced that they are banned that
they're not going to fly the flight till
the next morning they hadn't didn't have
enough passengers and I was damned if I
was going to wait till the next morning
and so I went to the back of the airport
and I borrowed a blackboard and I
scribbled Virgin Airlines as a joke
thirty-nine dollars one way to the
British Virgin Islands and went around
all the passengers and I managed to fill
up my first light and and when I got to
the BVI the guy on my left you know
turned to me and said you sharpen up the
service abyssion you could be in the
airline business and and and the next
day and anyway the night went well the
next area
oh she's not my wife solji oh well then
later either day and the next hour rang
up Boeing and I said I'm thinking agoing
to be in a line business so in fact I
just had my test flight and they do you
have any secondhand seven for sevens for
sale and the person who took the phone
call I thought he was going to put the
phone down on me but he you know held on
in there
so he said well you know what does your
company do and I said well you know
we're a record company we've got the
Rolling Stones we got the Sex Pistols
would and again he didn't sound very
very you know they said what's the name
of the company and I said virgin and
there was a long pause and he said well
it will send a salesman to see you but
and
the name like virgin and I just hope
your airline goes the whole way is the
things that frustrate you and do you
think you can do it better then if you
have a business get it get it get it
going I so I think and you know at all I
can say is don't don't get down at the
moment I mean all of us do get down it's
cool look look 420 leave school and you
can can follow your dreams and
concentrate on things you love I mean if
you love your film or theater or art you
know put more effort into that rather
than the things you don't do that you're
not good at